les professionnels du monde médical à la
réunion se rencontre pour débattre du
développement de lits santé dans l'océan
indien les échanges traiteront de
l'évolution numérique du parcours de
santé du malade avec au coeur du système
un meilleur partage de l'information
entre les différents acteurs médicaux ça
apporte et donc un gain de temps parce
que les médecins auront les résultats de
façon beaucoup plus précoce aurons les
résultats n'ont que plus rapidement ce
qui permet ce qui leur permettra donc
d'anticiper et non pas d'attendre que la
que le patient viennent avec les
résultats et donc ça permettra donc de
pouvoir s'entretenir de façon plus
précoce et de pouvoir éventuellement
soit donnée donc des pistes de
traitements ou sinon que pouvoir
adresser beaucoup plus rapidement
si jamais il y a des des analyses
complémentaires des examens faire de
façon plus urgente chez le médecin
traitant ou bien chez les spécialistes
pour sa santé le projet de loi santé
prévoit la mise en place dès fin 2010
est du carnet de santé numérique
chaque assuré disposera d'un dossier
informatique contenant son parcours
médical des informations qui
amélioreront la prise en charge du
malade
c'est finalement j'irai de permettre aux
patients de rester à domicile le plus
longtemps possible
finalement les systèmes d'information et
les échanges d'information jusqu'au
domicile du patient
qu'on permette finalement une prise en
charge au domicile qui est pratiquement
là pratiquement aussi sécurisé que à
l'hôpital du fait de ces informations et
de ce numérique qui arrive au domicile
pendant toute une journée les acteurs de
la santé aborderont différentes
thématiques comme le numérique outils de
refondations du système de santé
la télémédecine dans l'océan indien les
innovations médicales
le département de la réunion encourage
le développement de ces nouvelles
technologies au de stimuler le
département veut dire que cette
évolution numérique doit être au
bénéfice d'un plus grand nombre
que ce soit dans les technologies de
pointe en chirurgie et il est rare que
ce soit dans l'est
dans les ehpad au niveau de la prise en
charge des personnes âgées
que ce soit dans les pmi que ce soit en
hôpital de jour que ce soit dans le
social le département accompagne cette
évolution technologique pour permettre
un mieux vivre la population
cette rencontre régionale est une
réflexion qui complétera la mise en
place de la stratégie nationale de lits
santé d'ici 2020